I read this yesterday and I thought you
know Pat forty wrote this so he could
get on a radio show I think I mean I
think this is what he did he wrote you
know column and he's kind of asking
about Alabama's Alabam how great are
they all time here and I thought you
know Pat is trolling me and and I bit
Yahoo Sports National College columnist
and Pat joins us now well done well done
Pat you you did your job every call am i
right I think with the goal going in is
going to be good enough to get me on all
right what did you take away from this
of al'lat
we don't know what's gonna happen the
rest of the season but you asked the
question now why did you ask the
question now of Alabama's greatness
historically after seeing what they did
to LSU that stood out you know I mean
I'm not sure LSU is a great team but
it's a very good team and that
environment was crazy and they totally
dominated them and that's when I started
thinking okay this Alabama team looks
like one of the best teams I've ever
seen and so I you know one to go back
and look at the numbers and see how they
stack up and in terms of just dominance
of opponents they stack up very well
with certainly all the undefeated
champions of the 21st century and many
of the great teams of the last 50 years
as you said it's early I mean it's nine
games in they gotta win six more games
but they're they're on their way I'm
also wondering because I remember those
great Oklahoma Nebraska teams and their
strength of schedule couldn't have been
very good because you know that back
then Kansas was horrible I mean you had
Baylor was horribly these teams that
they sort of steamrolled were horrible
so I don't know if you took in strength
of schedule
or you know whatever kind of data
analytics that you could provide with
that to say all right strength of
schedule for Florida State a couple of
years ago was this Oklahoma in the you
know early 70s was this yeah I really
didn't factor that in it's hard to say
the one thing that you did have back
then I mean there was the big eight they
would play seven conference games which
left plenty of noncoms games and people
played pretty good schedules not
necessarily Nebraska Nebraska didn't but
you know Oklahoma would play USC you
know there there were some really good
intersectional games then more of them
probably then than now you know I think
we could probably look at Florida State
schedule in 2013 to and say the ACC at
that point wasn't great you know Clemson
hadn't become Clemson that we see now
and the rest of that league wasn't that
great but I I think yeah if you go
through an FCC schedule like Alabama's
going through and you're just beating
the snot out of everybody they're pretty
darn good we were talking about the
greatness of a to a tongue of AI Aloha
and and you know people are gonna look
at his numbers and say oh my god
you know that touchdown to interception
ratio and I said you know let's pump the
brakes he's probably gonna win the
Heisman I have no problem with that
but when you want to compare great
seasons as I always mention if if Johnny
Manziel doesn't throw a touchdown pass
he could still have won the Heisman
Trophy he led the SEC in rushing so you
run for 21 touchdowns in 1,400 yards as
a quarterback I think it's the greatest
season that a quarterbacks ever had you
know individually what do you think it
was incredible there's no doubt about it
I mean he was a special talent it's it's
sad that what's become of that talent
but is there a better citizen is there a
better season than manziel's boy without
having figures in front of me I mean
that's that's way up there it's way way
up there I mean Mayfield season last
year was awfully awfully good it's the
number one pass efficiency season he
could run a little he couldn't run like
Manziel they would I mean to work and
Ronnie just doesn't want to I think we
saw that he was dead a 44-yard touchdown
through our defense he just keep he's
chosen not to he's been banged up some
and I and he's too good sitting in the
pocket and throwing we had Jim Harbaugh
on first hour and I starting to look at
their schedule here that you had the
Ohio State game
if if they beat Ohio State are they
gonna play they're gonna make the final
four is that a guarantee you think or is
there a chance if Georgia beats Alabama
Alabama doesn't drop out of the top four
but is Michigan gonna stay in the kind
of you know so I'm just sort of looking
at
this game of musical chairs sure no
that's that that would be a really
interesting little tenor people in
Georgia somehow beats Alabama and you
get a bunch of teams there with one loss
and you're comparing resumes Georgia
against Michigan hmm the other thing too
I I don't think I think if Notre Dame
loses a game I don't think they would
still stay ahead of Michigan but they
would have the head-to-head yeah over
Michigan and there would be an argument
there so if yeah if Alabama gets beaten
this thing gets really interesting and
contentious but I'm not sure Alabama
gets beat I mentioned the USC situation
yesterday that I don't think there's
going to be a change not because it's
maybe not warranted or it is warranted
but they don't have a school president
there's other drama lawsuits going on in
there
it just feels like clay Helton might buy
himself another year here what do you
think yeah no I agree with you I mean I
think it would cost a ton so it's a buy
him out right pound as you said it's
it's kind of a very unstable situation
there you know and I'm not sure Lynn
Swann is necessarily in the you know
coach search mode that kind of guy I
mean you know we'll see what he would do
if it comes to that it might come to
that next year but I agree I think
Helton yes another year everybody likes
play Helton they just wish it was a
better coach he he has not done a great
job there other than when he had Sam
Donnell without saying Arnold his record
is his darn near 500 and so he he will
definitely have a lot to prove next year
but I think he makes it to next year
they can still win the pac-12 south or
what little consolation that is would
you bet that Urban Meyer is back next
year I would bet against if I had to I I
don't think he will be back I can't say
that with any great certainty but I just
I don't think his health is good whether
it's mental whether it's physical or
it's a combination thereof you know I
think that the the melodrama in August
took a toll on him and especially if
this season doesn't end well you know if
they lose to Michigan State and or lose
to Michigan I I wouldn't be surprised at
all to see him step away are the two
best potential
old prospect coaches in the state of
Oklahoma well that's a good question I
mean I would certainly say Lincoln Riley
is but I you know what I think the pros
really like Jeff Brohm at Purdue you
know I think that he would be an
attractive time babe they like people
that can do things in the quarterbacks
you know I know you guys were talking
about Josh McDaniels and people that
work with quarterbacks and you know
Brahm Brompton do that Lincoln Reilly
certainly can do that I mean what he's
done with Tyler Murray has been as good
as what he did with Baker Mayfield and
Mariza first year starter so I think
those two guys would be very attractive
amongst others good to talk to you thank
you again and I'll keep reading the
columns and see if you're trolling me to
get back on the show every day I'm
setting the bar at the Dan Patrick show
and that's a high bar thank you Thank
You Pat for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]